you accidentally called one and two once
and hung just in time
but that's rather not how we see it
if you accidentally call one one two
please hang on the line
until you are a colleague
of the emergency room
and answer the critical questions honestly
that will be asked by this colleague
the colleague has to check at that time
or you, for example,
not under duress from someone
must say you accidentally
so called
it is important here
that you really answer honestly
and if it were the case that you once one one
two calls and thinks
well it's all solved and you hung up anyway
please call back to zero 908 eight four four
tell what just happened
why you hung
because this takes a lot of time
as the colleague
of the emergency room must find out who called
if that colleague also has to call back
so to verify what's going on
and we prefer to use that time for people
who really need our help
so you call by accident
stick around
answer the critical questions honestly
that are asked
and you hung up now
then call back via zero 900 eight eight four four
no urgency
police and explain neatly what just happened